yeah welcome to this video 5 night game
again against endless fighter forgot
about this the sky it doesn't have the
name in that this is our leadership I
lost against him before bangladesh they
don't exactly have many grand masters
and but i don't know who that is ok we
have a rillo pass though lied with 66
such as some really popular in recent
times it's a mostly due to the marshal
being such a such a nuisance 93 unknown
all kinds of stuff is probably possible
here
Bishop 695 yeah the knight on c3 years
so slightly irritating me maybe I can do
this rook e8 Bishop f8 business it's
probably not the best way to play that
hmm okay
hmm it bit annoying him may be here and
Bishop Bishop d7 lobby seven actually
probably him this Bishop is not doing
much on b7 again now he alone have the
FL yeah white is better somewhat it's
not like him it's um it's an enormous
advantage hood kind of firm nagging
pressure it's got the aiport the a file
and I don't have many active
possibilities
hmm
I don't need to get rid of this Bishop
somehow
hmm it just wants to win an exchange
absolutely didn't realize that smooth
was even possible
195 we should be eight
yo can I check here bishop system yeah
probably the best choice I mean
relatively speaking it's just various
ways of being an exchange down
so yeah I forgot to have got to bishops
at least maybe I'm I need to open it up
here it's not not clear I mean okay he's
got look so opening it up its double
edged but dumb ships need some same room
as well okay it's probably going to play
a form or plain ig6 getting at this
bishop
hmm yeah I didn't see Bishop a summary
and maybe maybe a five was also not the
the toughest way to to defend no with
the two bishops gone it's um probably
very bad
yeah also this be five bonus of course a
problem it's a constant very the only a
slight count placer some the kingside I
try to go Queen g60 em I'm taking d3 and
possibly Bishop h3 coming hmm the ship
the ship we should give form we should d
three
maybe maybe this is still a bit tricky
at least look f3 I mean no rook moves
and then e for rock f3
I opposite before now he's he probably
wants to yeah he probably needs to play
crew g3 now
so this is actually a not one hundred
percent clear it's a it's a couple of
pawns two pawns yeah I know I know he
wants to wants to double on the seventh
but damn
but the bishop has is not not bad its
covering age 7 wow he's completely
ignoring all this since always grade Oh
Kim Jong threatening p3 now how to see
to see him how does he prevent all this
many okay maybe he can he can probably
stop the pawns but it's it's not one
hundred percent clear okay so i go here
covering c5 and attending bishop c2 and
then be three and ce4 i can he probably
needs to use his pawns to get anywhere
but this is really a good Bishop
Jeff g6
g6 winning I don't see a doctor I'm
threatening c3 and p2
the past points9 photoshop h7 now
there's no other way to do it now the
sea poem
just promoting him very lucky check
check check check check check check
check check check Jeff wait yeah just a
very very lucky win I mean you really
outplayed me but right here this is
probably still winning but it needs it
needs some precise play I think and
probably at one point looks it's heaven
awesome yeah yeah the computer gifts
this is winning I am I'm willing to
believe that but it's not clear that the
computer is really calculating deep
enough at least for our foreign game
against between humans this is tricky
karachi answer it's a draw according to
computer then this losses rook age to be
six supposed to be a draw yeah difficult
difficult to see how okay I know it's
not difficult he just puts it there and
whenever I play be too he just sex the
roofer two pawns okay
okay yeah I'm winning yeah just lucky I
mean I overlooked this Bishop a seven
moves winning the exchange and after
that it was us was very bad thanks for
watching